[Musique]
comment se fait-il qu'on me considère
souvent
dans un certain monde littéraire
scientifique comme un homme pessimiste
je ne combats solitaire je ne cacherai
pas que j'ai un tempérament
pessimiste je ne cacherai pas que je ne
me sens pas pleinement heureux dans le
siècle où le hasard m'a fait naître je
ne cacherai pas que j'ai de très grande
inquiétude sur le futur de l'humanité
si elle continue à se laisser à cette
incroyable
prolifération qui ne laissera plus je
n'irai pas à nous mais en tout cas nos
petits-enfants ou arrière petits enfants
si ça continue à ce rythme qu'un mètre
carré des espaces pour se tenir sur
notre terre qui n'est pas indéfiniment
extensible mais ce pessimisme me paraît
être après tout offrir à l'optimisme sa
meilleure chance parce que c'est à la
condition d'être très pessimiste que
nous prendrons conscience des dangers
qui nous menacent c'est à la condition
d'être très pessimiste que nous aurons
le courage d'adopter les solutions
nécessaires et que donc peut-être nous
pouvons recommencer à avoir une certaine
dose d'optimisme disons modéré pensez
vous que les sociétés primitives ou des
primitives et des choses à nous
apprendre lesquels il y en a énormément
et nous apprendre et à beaucoup de
points de vue et si ce n'était pas le
cas il n'y aurait pas lieu qu'il existe
de l'ethnologue en premier lieu elle
constitue c'est l'expérience tout fait
que nous sommes bien obligés d'aller
chercher là où elles sont puisque nous
n'avons pas le moyen à la façon de nos
collègues physiciens chimistes
biologistes
de volonté d expérience dans un
laboratoire ce qui signifierait pour
nous fabriquer des sociétés humaines ou
bien y introduire des modifications qui
nous permettrait d'en étudier les
conséquences et ses milliers de sociétés
qui ont existé à la surface de la terre
et dont chacune représentées une
combinaison originale le croyances de
coutume d'institutions de règles
juridiques nous fournissent l'équivalent
de l'expérience
scientifique
en second lieu ce sont des sociétés qui
possèdent un savoir d'un raffinement
tout à fait extraordinaire en ce qui
concerne les ressources de leur milieu
naturel
je n'ai pas besoin de vous dire qu'une
quantité des substances que nous
consommons au que nous utilisons à
commencer par le tabac au maïs ou la
quinine et bien d'autres choses les
produits de terre
tomates enfin j'en passe le coton cetera
proviennent de ces sociétés qui les
utilisée depuis des millénaires et que
la pharmacopée a énormément à apprendre
de la connaissance que ces sociétés ont
de leurs plantes et de leurs propriétés
pharmaceutiques et puis enfin et je
dirais surtout nous avons à apprendre
d'elle
au une certaine modestie et une certaine
sagesse enfin ce sont des sociétés qui
ont su réaliser ce miracle de rester
depuis des millénaires en équilibre avec
leur milieu naturel
grâce à toutes sortes de croyances que
nous mêmes nous appelons des
superstitions d'ailleurs mais qui toutes
tendent à respect de toutes les formes
de la vie qu'il s'agisse des formes
animales ou des formes végétales et de
ce point de vue là je crois que notre
société qui depuis si longtemps traite
l'homme comme le seigneur est le maître
de la création dont il peut disposer à
sa guise sans aucun égard pour
le bloc terrestre qui laissera à ses
successeurs je crois que nos sociétés
ont beaucoup à apprendre d'elle
[Musique]